[Music]
[Applause]
it's bringing Tony Dungy the Hall of
Famer former coach with the Buccaneers
and the Colts and of course football
night in America analyst Tony uh Peyton
Manning talked about adjustments that
you make at halftime that you know he
said it's one of the the great myths
that there's just not that much time to
make adjustments here uh do you agree
with what Peyton said
I do let me tell you a funny story Dan
about the biggest uh adjustment we made
we're in the AFC Championship game
against New England we're losing 21-6
you only have 12 minutes during halftime
so you get into the locker room you
probably got nine minutes left guys have
to go to the bathroom get their pads
changed all of that everybody we're 15
down everybody's hyped up talking
assistant coaches want to talk we
finally got it all done and I'm about
ready to talk and make these huge
adjustments and give them a great speech
the guy knocks on the door and says we
got 30 seconds so you come out for
kickoff so I said hey we're playing
terrible if we don't start playing
better we're going to lose
and that was the big halftime assessment
in the motivational speech we went out
scored 32 points in the second half
didn't change anything just did what we
did a little better and that's usually
what happened we had Doug Peterson on
and uh he was telling uh Kaylee Hartung
our our field reporter you know walking
to into the locker room hey we just got
to Chip Away we just got to get our
compulsion do a little bit better that's
what it's basically all about you throw
out a few plays that don't look good you
accentuate some things that did look
good but you aren't making major changes
in there yeah and and to stay with your
game plan if you know that your game
plan is solid there are a couple of
fluky plays there Ricochet there's a
intercept you know all of those things
and it's not like the Chargers offense
was great it was you know Asante Samuel
yeah exactly and I thought you know Doug
Peterson where you just say hey let's
just continue to do and you said
something that would ever remember and
it was really prophetic because you said
score stop score now all of a sudden
you've changed the game and that's what
happened with uh with Jacksonville
yeah and that's uh that was really the
the basis of my talk in that
championship game hey there are three
scores ahead of us if we don't do
anything early on in the third quarter
they're just going to put it in cruise
control but I'll tell you what if we
stop them
get the ball and score and make it a two
score game now they've got to keep
playing and that's when we'll come back
and we've got the whole second half to
do it so we don't have to win this game
in the next 10 minutes but we do have to
stop them we do have to score and that's
exactly what Jacksonville did they
stopped the first ride they scored they
got the crowd back in it and then it was
a ball game
what did the Chargers fail to do in the
second half that we maybe didn't see or
we should notice
well part of it what gets me frustrated
is you have these game plans and you
have an idea of what you're going to do
when you go in and the charges told us
we did the production meeting before and
they said we're going to go up Tempo
fast against these guys and we're going
to throw they've got the 28th rated pass
defense so they do that in the first
half they get some breaks some short
Fields but now you're up 27 nothing so
you don't have to keep going up Tempo
and you don't have to keep throwing they
only ran the ball eight times after they
got 27-0 lead and that's what frustrated
me as a defensive coach we would get in
those situations with with Peyton I'd
walk over to Tom Moore our offensive
coordinator okay we're going to slow
down I didn't even have to do it because
Peyton knew it we're going to slow down
we're going to use the 40 second clock
up we're going to snap the ball with one
second on the clock we're going to run
we're not going to run out of bounds
we're not going to throw in complete
passes uh we're just going to adjust a
little bit and make sure we play sound
and that's what I thought the charges
didn't do in the second half
what role would you play with Brett
Maher the Cowboys kicker
uh usually that that's a one-off
situation uh I was at the game and we
couldn't believe how he was just missing
and and just like he'd lost all his
confidence this guy's a good kicker he's
kicked well now people told me he's been
a little bit different on grass as
opposed to at home I don't know that for
a fact they're going to another grass
field but here's what I would say look
hey we have total confidence in you
don't even worry about last week it's
practice getting back in your routine in
your groove and we aren't going to let
anything affect us but uh that was
really I've never seen a performance
like that okay but after he misses three
Tony
what would you have said to him
um I would have said
um just relax kick off well one for two
and we aren't kicking anymore
so just make sure you can kick off well
would you have benched him and gone for
two
yes yes I would have at that point
because I don't want him to continue on
more in that slump and that's they they
did try one more extra point but they
basically when they got in field goal
range they went for it Jack scored on
the one roll out on fourth down uh yeah
unless you get into a position where a
field goal has to win it for you I think
you just put him on ice right then
because he was he was definitely his
fundamentals his thought process was
messed up I had mentioned uh on the show
that I'd never pick against Tom Brady
I'd pick against the Buccaneers but not
Tom Brady I didn't think Tampa was good
at all this year but they still had Tom
Brady uh what do you make of the Brady
situation when he was walking off the
field and acknowledging his family and
the crowd even how he addressed the
media what do you think his future is
my sense is that he still wants to play
I get the vibe that he's he's not going
to play here uh we'll see what happens
I'm sure they're going to talk him into
trying to come back and play I don't
think he wants to go out on a year like
this uh so we'll see what happens but it
was a disappointing ending I was
surprised I thought the Bucks would win
I didn't think against a Dallas defense
that is has a great pass rush but you
know is not as good against the run I
didn't think you'd see 66 passes in 12
runs that that surprised me a little bit
yeah that discrepancy that's all it's
rare when somebody's throwing that many
times and they win a game we're talking
to the Hall of Famer Tony Dungy you did
talk about Dallas you play on Monday
night because you're the Cowboys they
want to showcase you now you gotta go
back home and then travel again going
out to San Francisco and judging from
your Tweet you don't think Dallas has
much of a chance in San Francisco why
and I brought it up last year when they
changed uh the schedule and went to
Monday night I understand morning Monday
Night Football and stretch the weekend
out but it is blatantly unfair in the
postseason that's exactly why we stopped
having Monday night games in the last
week of the regular season because that
team has at a disadvantage the next week
now you you go here we we had this
situation in 2001. I was coaching the
Buccaneers we played at the Rams on
Monday night and then at Cincinnati the
following Sunday and I researched it
because I wanted our guys to make sure
they got their rest I wanted to be able
to emphasize how tough it is I think at
that time only three teams in the
history of the 30 years of Monday Night
had been able to win back to back Monday
night and Sunday Road games the league
doesn't even try to schedule that way
they do all they can to avoid that in
the regular season well now we've
created it where one team and this one
is even exacerbated because San
Francisco played on Saturday so they've
got two more days rest Dallas is working
on a road Monday night game short week
comeback flight out to San Francisco and
yeah you're going to say no excuses and
this is the playoffs he's a good team
but that that is so unfair when you're
talking about playoff football now yeah
if you win you get the buy you you want
to get that I understand that and you
should get a break but San Francisco and
Dallas are in the same boat one team
should not have two extra days to
prepare
how do you think it plays out in
Baltimore with Lamar and the Ravens
they get Lamar situated with a long-term
contract uh they need and they they
could have been a great football team
this year now the the tough part with
Lamar and his style he's going to get
some injuries and I think that's what
Baltimore is trying to factor in how
much can we guarantee how much do we put
out for this quarterback who is great
but maybe injured at times and I hope
they come to a meeting of the minds I
hope he stays there because they built
this offense around him and I know those
players really want to play with him
they like him uh hopefully it works out
yeah but you're talking like a coach you
got to talk like a businessman in this
situation because he's looking at these
guaranteed contracts and probably saying
hey uh I want what DeShaun Watson got I
Want It All guaranteed
sure he is and he's feeling like that's
what he deserves and the coach
on the The Raven side is saying yes you
do deserve that but you're right the
business people have to say well we do
that tomorrow and you deserve it we give
it to you but that's going to hamstring
us if you're not there if you're injured
and we're paying you this money and
we've got to find another quarterback uh
that's that's the top Balancing Act and
I can see both sides of the coin when
Sean Payton goes into interview is he
being interviewed by the team
like are they pitching no no no he is
interviewing them and he's saying here's
what I want here's what I need I've got
four or five other teams I need my own
general manager I need this type of
long-term contract I need these
facilities I need this type of power now
are we on the same page and if the team
says no he packs up and goes to the next
next team where do you think he'll end
up
I really don't know uh because it is a
combination you've got to have an
attractive uh situation for him but then
you've also got to satisfy New Orleans
uh Carolina I don't know if they have
enough draft choices to pay uh New
Orleans to play against Sean Payton
twice a year if I'm the Saints I don't
know if I want that so I might want to
send them to the AFC
um I I really don't know I I think it's
kind of you could see where the Saints
deny the request for Carolina
oh no they they hey bro you can talk to
them but it's going to take four number
one drafts okay what did John Gruden get
from what did the Raiders get for John
Gruden two ones and two twos right yeah
I think so
yeah and I could see Carolina's saying I
need three one uh and and we're not
gonna give you our Super Bowl winning
coach to play against us twice a year
unless you really Sweden the pot yeah
has uh Colts owner Jim irsay asked for
your input with the head coaching
position
no I haven't reached out to him he
hasn't reached out to me and I've been
busy uh with the broadcasts and things
I'm keeping my eye on it from afar but I
hope they uh come up with the right
person
that person's not Jeff Saturday
well I think Jim wanted it to be and I
think he still probably wants it to be
it's a little hard to sell with seven
straight losses uh I know they're going
to talk to a lot of people uh Jim Murphy
will he'll figure it out I do believe
that he'll figure out who the best
person for this franchise is
the surprise game will come from the
surprise outcome will come from what
game
this weekend
there there's some
ensco is playing the best football uh
and with Dallas having a short week
it'd be tough for me to see Dallas win
in that game Jacksonville our game on
NBC Jacksonville going to KC Andy Reed's
been great after the buy Patrick Mahomes
is great there but Jacksonville's got a
little something uh that they they feel
great about themselves they've got this
Mojo going the first game they they did
some good things
um I I'm looking forward to our game I
really am if I gave you Tom Brady for a
year Aaron Rodgers for a year same price
foreign
wow
um I don't know Aaron that well but I
know Tom Brady I've been around him down
here I know how
his competitive Juices Flow I know how
he would be there 24 7 in the off-season
getting used to his new teammates I I if
I had to wager on one guy or the other I
would take Tom just because I know a
little bit more about him and I know
what competitive fire he's going to
bring and how he's going to bring out
the best in in the guys he's around
I give you Justin Herbert for five years
or Joe burrow for five years
wow
um we're not playing softball today Tony
yeah
Joe burrow is has a great physical
Talent Justin Herbert has unbelievable
physical Talent Joe burrow has the way
to get away from the rust and escape and
make plays uh with his legs
that that's a tough one based on what
I've seen
I'd probably say Joe burrow just
slightly just slightly if you're the
Bears
you keep Justin fields or if you trade
him and you got the number one pick
overall
I do I keep Justin Fields I build around
him and I see who is going to be in that
auction for that number one pick you
want Bryce uh I I'll give him to you
it's going to take a lot and then I'm
going to get my other people around
Justin fields and build that I didn't
understand Robert Quinn and roquan Smith
those guys seem to fit mattybrus's
defense uh you know that's right from
Indy those guys fit they didn't pay them
uh okay I get it but those are the kind
of guys I'm looking for I need four or
five guys like that so if I can trade
down a little bit and and pick up some
of that that's what I would do do you
live in Brady's neighborhood
uh no I'm probably
15 minutes away
have you driven by the house though just
you know you're out with you can
probably see it from from where it's
pretty big how how much bigger is
Brady's house than yours five five times
and you got five times I've got 11 kids
I've got 11 kids so
you can you can imagine how big his
house is do you ever forget one of your
kids names
I don't forget the names I sometimes
forget them when I'm supposed to pick
them up from school or I'm supposed to
be a game uh or we're at Busch Gardens
and we don't have all of them uh but no
I know the names I just can't keep up
with all of them when I get the
Christmas card I need it's almost like I
need a program I need you know a roster
there with the lineup there tone yeah
yeah I think we're done though I do
think we're done at 11. well my best to
the family and uh great to talk to you
thank you Tony thanks DT always good
being on with you brother that's uh Tony
Dungy